On February 28, 1953, two scientists at the
University of Cambridge's Cavendish Laboratory
found the secret of life.
Francis Crick and his young American assistant,
James Watson, discovered the structure of
DNA.
And for that, they would go on to win the
Nobel Prize.
But they couldn’t have done it without help.
That help came from Rosalind Franklin, a 32-year-old
physical chemist who was little known outside
of her own scientific circles.
But, here’s the thing.
It was her research that pointed Crick and
Watson in the right direction.
Watson had glimpsed one of Rosalind Franklin’s
X-ray photographs of DNA, which provided the
pivotal clue that helped determine DNA’s
double helix structure, the twisted ladder
that gave rise to modern molecular biology.
Based on her notebooks, it’s clear that
Franklin was on the cusp of making the discovery
herself.
Despite the critical role she did play, she
received no recognition for her work.
Franklin was determined to become a scientist
at the age of twelve and overcame all obstacles
to get there.
England at that time did not exactly favor
women.
She was one of just 500 women accepted into
the University of Cambridge - the quota set
for female admissions to ensure they didn’t
exceed 10% of the male undergraduate body.
She pursued her studies in physical chemistry
amid the terror of the London blitz in World
War Two.
Early in her career, she helped the war effort
by investigating how coal changed when subjected
to heat using a method called X-ray crystallography.
When X-rays are shone onto a crystal, they
"bounce off" or "diffract" in specific patterns.
By studying these patterns, scientists can
determine the structure of the crystal.
She used the same technique to examine DNA,
which isn't a typical crystal, but she managed
to treat it like one.
With the help of a young doctoral student,
Raymond Gosling, they shone X-rays on a tiny
DNA strand - the thickness of a strand of
hair - for 100 hours at a super close range
- 15 mm - in order to get a clear picture.
Franklin's X-ray images of DNA, especially
the iconic Photograph 51, displayed a distinctive
X-shaped pattern.
This pattern hinted at DNA’s real shape,
which resembled a spiral staircase or twisted
ladder.
Interpreting the image required Franklin to
perform mathematical computations to analyze
the pattern in an attempt to reveal its structure.
While Franklin was busy doing just that at
King’s College London, where she worked,
Crick and Watson gained access to her X-ray
image.
How?
Franklin’s assistant Gosling showed the
work to the assistant head of the biophysics
unit at King’s College London, Maurice Wilkins.
Wilkins was supposed to be Franklin’s supervisor.
But the two didn’t really get along.
Then, in January 1953, James Watson visited
King’s College London.
And Wilkins showed it to his friend and rival
without Franklin’s knowledge or permission.
Wilkins didn't realize the impact the photo
would have on Watson who later recalled: ‘The
instant I saw the picture my mouth fell open
and my pulse began to race.’
During dinner, Wilkins went a step further
and gave Watson the necessary dimensions of
the DNA sample in Photo 51, which was then
used to develop the structure of DNA.
And then there was more….
Watson and Crick later received an internal
King’s College London research report containing
Franklin’s unpublished results about her
DNA diffraction images.
It was given to them by Max Perutz, a Cavendish
colleague, who got his hands on it during
a visit to King’s College.
As Brenda Maddox writes in her biography about
Rosalind Franklin: “The MRC report was all
Watson and Crick could hope for — as valuable
as an enemy’s code book.”
From that report, they determined that the
two strands of the DNA helix must run in opposite
directions, like two escalators side-by-side,
one going up and one going down.
Franklin hadn’t yet made this connection.
But she was very close to figuring it out.
Her notebook reveals she was contemplating
whether DNA had a double-helical, 2-chain
structure around the time Watson and Crick
got their hands on her report.
Max Perutz defended handing over the report
to his Cambridge colleagues, “I was inexperienced
and casual in administrative matters and,
since the report was not confidential, I saw
no reason for withholding it.”
He later admitted he should have asked for
permission from Franklin “as a matter of
courtesy.”
As the report wasn’t confidential, it is
possible Franklin knew that her research had
already made its way to Cambridge.
Regardless, the Cambridge scientists did not
inform Franklin that they were using her data.
Given all that she knew, how could Rosalind
Franklin have missed connecting the dots herself?
It boiled down to her personality.
She was the kind of scientist who believed
in thoroughness.
She didn't want to jump to conclusions based
on one image.
DNA exists in different structures, notably
the A-form and B-form.
While Photograph 51 showcased the B-form,
Franklin was captivated by the intricate details
of the A-form, believing it held more significant
and yet-unraveled insights, especially given
the richer data it presented to crystallographers.
So, she temporarily set aside the now-iconic
Photo 51
It's something like being handed the key to
a treasure chest but choosing to examine it
closely to make sure it would work before
using it.
Watson and Crick didn’t make that mistake.
They knew what they had and quickly brought
it to the world’s attention.
On April 25, 1953, James Watson and Francis
Crick published a landmark paper in Nature,
proposing the double helix as the long elusive
structure of DNA, a discovery that earned
them the Nobel Prize in physiology or medicine
a decade later.
In the final paragraph of their paper, they
acknowledged that they had been “stimulated
by a knowledge of the general nature of the
unpublished experimental results and ideas”
of two scientists at King’s College London,
Wilkins and Franklin.
In 1958, Franklin died of ovarian cancer,
possibly caused by her repeated exposure to
X-rays during her lifetime.
She was just 37 years old.
Franklin’s early death also meant she missed
out on the Nobel Prize - which is not given
posthumously.
Neither Watson nor Crick mentioned her when
they accepted their awards in 1962, though
Wilkins, who also received the Nobel prize,
did.
Historians say there’s no evidence Franklin
felt aggrieved by what happened.
However, she may have felt differently had
she lived long enough to read an appallingly
disrespectful book written by Watson and published
in 1968 in which he admitted he and Crick
used Franklin’s data without her knowledge,
writing: “Rosy, of course, did not directly
give us her data.
For that matter, no one at King’s realized
they were in our hands.”
Notice how he wrote disparagingly of Franklin,
calling her Rosy?
And he wasn’t alone in his casual diminishment
of her.
When Franklin prepared to leave King’s College
for Birkbeck, part of the University of London,
Wilkins wrote to Crick: ‘Our dark lady is
leaving us next week.’
Over the years, there has been a growing recognition
of the “dark lady’s” contributions to
the discovery of the structure of DNA.
With more people championing her role in one
of the most significant scientific discoveries
of the 20th century.
Finally giving her the credit that she didn’t
get when she was still alive.
Franklin’s work was heavily rooted in scientific
thinking.
You can practice thinking with scientific
principles with Brilliant, a website and app
where you can learn through physical insight
by solving scientific puzzles.
And it’s FREE for you to try out.
There’s something for everyone on Brilliant,
like bruhsing up on your skills in math, data
science, and computer science.
Whether you’re just starting out or you’d
like to dive deeper into my advanced topics,
there’s something for everyone, and you
can learn at your own pace.
There are no tests.
And if you ever get stuck, you can view the
explanation to see where you went wrong.
Brilliant is part of my daily routine.
I like to take a few minutes out of my day
to improve my analytical thinking skills by
going through their Logic puzzles.
You can try out Brilliant for free for 30
days by clicking on the custom link in my
description: brilliant.org/newsthink.
And the first 200 people who sign up with
my custom link will get 20% their Premium
subscription, which gives you access to all
of their offerings.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.